hi I'm 20 my name is Carlo and our talk
is called new entity query functionality
version 12
hi I'm Tony and this is Carlo I normally
work on the anti framework and Carlo
works in the relational database group
and you might be wondering what these
things have to do or what they have in
common all right we are talking about it
jointly so I let Carlo explain it to you
okay so in the next hour we're gonna
divide things into first we're gonna
explain a little bit the current entity
framework and then we're gonna extend
with some new and interesting symbolic
heads to perform more complicated
queries and then in a second half hour
with Ricardo represent how all of this
connects to to sequel databases and how
we can use this as basically an ORM
without yo for databases okay so yeah so
as I said first we're gonna cover we're
gonna give like just a little of a recap
for people who are not familiar with the
entity framework then we're gonna
introduce entity function a bunch of new
entity class like structures and then
we're gonna show how it's possible to do
now crease that spanned multiple and his
types at the same time so let's get
started okay first of all we would like
to talk about entity value and T value
is the main resolver for entities and
entity value is the thing that takes you
from entities and properties and returns
values the structure is pretty simple
the first argument is either an entity
or a list of entities or empty class the
second argument is there a property list
of property or it could be even an anti
property class in general if you have an
entity and I on this property you will
get out something which is a scalar
could also be a list but in general it's
you want to think about it as a scalar
and then if in the second argument I put
an entity property then you will get a
list of values sorry if in the first
argument you have an entity class you
get a list of values one for each entity
in the entity class and instead if you
have a single entity as the first
argument and a list of entities at stand
an argument you get a list which
corresponds to the second argument in
the most general case you can put
basically lists in the first and second
argument and you get matrix of data so
for those of you
like thinking algebraically it's kind of
like an idiotic form and this is where
we'll see the connection to databases in
the next well in that half-hour
following this talk
okay so entity function what is it I
mean in the previous versions of the
entity framework if you wanted to do
something like this so let's take we
extract the population of Iceland then
we extract the surface of Iceland and we
want to compute the population density
we'd have to do two calls and then
compute the ratio on on the Wolfram
language side this so this is not very
desirable first of all because since
we're talking to an external service
these are two network round trips and
secondly this is not the case for
building entities but it will see it's
very important for databases you lose
atomicity and so who knows what happens
to the data between those two calls and
so what we want to introduce is a
construct which is called entity
function which is effectively it works
like a property but it's computed on the
fly and the reason why we introduce a
new symbol some some have criticized us
for this and notably it I who's always
complaining yeah
and we appreciate you for that there
isn't why we introduced a new symbol is
because by using a normal function in
there then people might get the
expectation that you can use whatever
like down values and connected to a
symbol and that is not the case there's
only very precise things that we can
send back to the framework so this
entity function basically has very
similar semantics to entity except in
some cases so this is how you would
write it down so what is entity classes
what is an entity class and any class in
general stands in for a list of entities
the difference between an entity class
or at least meant is that the entity
class is lazy so it will at the time
where you ask for entity value it will
resolve whatever whether its name or it
has a filter it will resolve what the
things that it contains are but it's
it's it's it's a symbolic construct so
the first entities that were present
that's sorry the first time T classes
that were present were named things like
G a noble gases etc and then after that
and as you can see basically performing
empty lists or entity on the entity
class and then passing a 20 volume or
doing any value directly on the entity
class effectively are the same thing
then at some point we introduced up they
introduced in pleased entity classes
where you have a property goes to an
operator form of a predicate that again
then get supplies to the density so this
basically selects it's like the function
selecting over language really the
elements that I have a density that is
greater than such so you can you can
either get the until list or you can
directly compute the density and you can
convince yourself that these are all
larger than 20 so okay so now I'm going
to let Tony speak a little bit maybe
I'll speak directly from here so I can
quote something if necessary so we are
introducing new ways to define entity
classes and why would you want to do
that for some simple reasons for
instance in an implicitly defined entity
class the order of the entities is not
defined so in some cases you might want
to sort them by a certain value of a
certain property or you might want to
filter them we could do that this
implicitly defined entity classes but
it's limited because you can specify a
predicate for a property now you can do
more the more complicated features are
aggregation and merging entity classes
but we get to that in a moment and with
these new features you will see the real
power of entity function it is useful in
its own but in these functions you will
see why it's necessary so first of all a
filtered entity class you have seen that
one before now
we're looking for elements this is
certain density greater than a certain
value and this one is a new way of
writing it now so a filtered entity
class starts with an entity class or a
type the type has a default entity class
namely the class of all entities so you
can interchangeably use an explicit
class or the type and then you specify a
predicate which is an entity function
those this new class it has the bird
class in its name you know behaves like
any other entity class it has properties
so you can retrieve the density of the
elements in that class and style it
nicely using the Association string now
you can also do new things that were not
possible before for instance you can
involve multiple properties in a single
condition there was something you
couldn't do before
sorted entity class so now you can
specify the order of the entities in
that class for instance sort planets by
the average diameter you can also sort
them in in descending order now or you
can sort them by another property and
now you can also sort them by an entity
function if you want to know the value
of that you can if you want to know the
value of that computed property you just
repeat it and to avoid s reputation we
introduce a new construct namely the
extended entity class so each entity
type has a list of properties and you
can introduce new properties for a given
entity type or an entity or an entity
class by extending it with a new
property in this case I introduce a
computed property using an entity
function and call it ratio and then I
retrieve that property for all the
entities in that class I can use that
property in a list of properties like
for like all the other properties so it
behaves exactly the same and now I can
rewrite the previous example without any
repetition so first I add the new
property to the planet to the list of
all planets then I sorted by that
property and then I retrieve it yeah so
that cleans up the code to specify such
an ordered and extended entity class in
this net example you can see how those
new constructs can nest now we are
getting to a more complicated feature
aggregation what does aggregation mean
consider you have a long list of values
and you want to reduce it to a single
value say I could say taking a total or
the mean you can do that in Mathematica
but depending on the back end this
operation can be done say on the
database so you don't have to retrieve
all of the data but just a single number
and in this case we start with a list of
all countries and we want to get the
total population of all the countries we
give the result a name total population
and then we retrieved it you see that
this one is in a list and you might be
wondering why so the general idea of
aggregation is you start with a list of
things in our case entities and then you
group those things by a certain
condition and then you aggregate over
the list of groups and that's why in
general you have a list here in this
case we didn't group at all so we have
just
the group in this case we want to group
the country's first by certain predicate
in this case the number of official
languages and then apply the aggregate
function to each of those groups so we
get a list of results and to demonstrate
again that we can nest those things we
can sort the result and miss dead I'm
gonna be I'm giving back to come okay
now one thing that I think is really
cool and really powerful is the fact
that in general in the entity framework
since the reference is to the other
types or to yourself
are returned as entities or list of
entities or entity classes that means
that in general you can chain the this
this sub value application of entity
value what this means is that we take
all the countries and then we extract
the capital C from each country and then
we extract the population of that
capital city and then we ask for
basically in this case we're filtering
and we're getting all the cities that
have a population that is larger than a
million so we're getting sorry we're
getting all the countries so as you can
see this is the first minimal example of
a query that is actually spending two
types because the country type has no
knowledge of the property of its capital
this is something that as we will see in
the next talk is extremely powerful
idiom for performing queries on
databases because in if you were to
write SQL by hand this would be would
require either a sub query or a join so
instead this is a very compact and easy
to read representation so on the other
hand sometimes you okay sometimes you
might need to do some more complicated
things so in this case let me go from
the inside out
explain what this is doing so merged
entity class is a construct that takes
twenty types and merged them at the
property level so what you get out is a
new type which has both the properties
of the first type in this case isotope
and the property of the second type that
is element in a way if you are familiar
with the Wolfram language function join
across this is exactly equivalent it's
actually a little bit more powerful and
and for those of you who are familiar
with Siebel this is join so what this
does then is after we have merged the
two types we are filtering them by the
group of the element and then we are
extracting a property of the isotope so
as you can see this is a period that
would be impossible to do without
knowledge of the two types at the same
time on the other hand we can get rid of
merged as I was saying before and this
thing can be written in a way that to me
is much more readable by chaining the
entity property extraction so you first
get the property element of the of the
isotope entity and then out of that to
extract the group and then you get
exactly the same result so element those
20d means just like in the syntax for
join across DC this is an equi-join
so you're extracting the property
element from the type isotope and then
you're comparing it with the whole
entity of the second type this can be
done with like real properties entities
kind of a fake property which means so
itself it's a special property alike
identity so that's yeah or if it if this
was object oriented that would be self
the whole object okay in general you
could also have an entity function on
the left or on the right or an entity
function of two arguments to write a
general condition for joining yes so for
example you could be asking I want to
merge I want the merchants across a
person with person itself and get all
the people there are younger than one
person
you get a huge emergency class one thing
to remember is that basically the merged
entity class will not necessarily have
the same cardinality of either of the
two I'm gonna repeat the question the
question is will the merge be repeated
when you when you extract things so one
thing to understand is that if you think
merged empty glass and you come to
places in another cell and you evaluate
that nothing happens
this fully symbolic so only when you do
entity value or sub value extraction
then the thing is computed and that
means that in general if you have one
merged entity glass even if you're
extracting 15 properties only one one
once the merge operation will be
performed and that also is highly
dependent on the backend so different
backends will optimize things like this
in completely different ways for example
this will get from there to a join in
SQL and then they have all sorts of
smart ways of optimizing this and not
perform the other product and them
filter for example that's an excellent
question I'm going to repeat again why
do we need all these different heads to
do these things and this was an idea we
toyed with so can we have something
which is like an entity class but then
we'll take another let's say another
argument that says perform a merge
perform a filter perform something like
that and the reason we decided to go
with different heads is that in the end
the the kind of operations you can
perform are five or six and this makes
it much more easily discoverable and
documentable so putting an arbitrary
third argument would have meant that
then you can list we you can do all
these six operations and people would
have tried to put all sorts of symbols
in there so the orange box you can get
either from the entity properties or if
you type an T property in that case
element group and evaluate it that's
just the boxes you evaluate an entity
propagate and it's it's just formatting
this is really it's not the result it's
just formatting this is just so I don't
know if you've seen there are many cases
in which in the Wolfram language we have
something even plot looks like something
fancy
we input form that's just a graphics
construct that's exactly the same just
make make boxes code not to make your
code look so this yellow box is still an
entity property yeah okay what else I
think this example is done yes okay so
okay so in what what we want to show
with this what we want to show is that
we have greatly extended the entity
query language and this is allows us to
do things that were not possible before
namely perform a quiz that can spend
multiple domains and you can ask
questions that were not possible before
about the data and this would allow us
to do extremely powerful things on
external sequel databases so stay tuned
for the next half hour there are still
challenges that we are we are facing so
if you have been to Tony's talk about
Sparkle we so some pure Sparkle queries
are supported on entities but what we
would like to do next is to integrate
Sparkle more tightly and in order to be
able to perform sparkle like
hierarchical recursive queries also on
other backhands like the built-in
entities and sequel so I guess that with
that we can conclude unless you have
something else to add we thank you and
we're open to questions
you